each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
good morning everyone and thanks for
coming down here on the day of caring
and so that we care about Peter Timmons
talk it is a pleasure to introduce Peter
and whom I met probably 15 years ago at
some conference in Germany and we both
come from Germany but we are met let's
say every other year on a conference but
our paths have been very different and
but now they seem to lead together again
and so Peter will talk a little bit
about web programming with objects and
new insights into exciting type systems
thanks a lot for joining us via ok yeah
thank you for the introduction welcome
and I would like to talk to you about a
little project that we are currently
having which involves web programming
and which got a little bit sidetracked
into a an enterprise in types type
systems so as a motivation for looking
at web programming and looking at
programming languages specialized for
dealing with that let's have a look at
the current state of the web so if you
look at at a modern web site ah then
you'll see basically two types of
content namely you have some static
content that is like pictures and text
and download downloadable items and then
there's also dynamic content that
depends on well whatever daytime who you
are current contents of a database and
so on and depending on what kind of web
page you're looking at then of more than
80 or even ninety percent of the content
is actually dynamically generated and
only your small parts are setting for
example if you look at search engines
new services and so on blogs forums then
you have such a high percentage of
dynamically generated stuff
and fortunately this is great news for
us as programmers because all this stuff
has to be programmed and maintained and
debugged and so on so we'll we'll be in
business for some time to come at least
then there's the other question what
tools we are using in order to do this
kind of programming task which is called
web programming and I think it's
rightfully called so because it has some
funny characteristics which are a little
bit different to other applications
other areas in which you do some
programming in particular in web
programming you usually distinguish
between two kinds of web programming
namely between server-side and
client-side web programming where the
server-side web programming is basically
some program that runs on your behalf on
the web server and client side means
that you're writing a program that runs
in one form or the other on your web
browser on your own machine and then
there are lots of partially historic
approaches to server-side programming so
there is the good old CGI then there are
scripting languages like Perl PHP Python
Ruby and so on and then there are
integrated solutions with application
servers like servlets JSP asp asp and so
on and i won't go into details for that
because that's not really the point I
want to make also for client-side web
programming there is well known
JavaScript and here probably have to
mention visual basic as well which you
can also use for web programming but all
of these approaches have a little bit of
a problem namely they are only targeted
at once one end of the of the website so
they are either they are the reside on
the server or they reside on the client
and making them communicate is involves
a non-trivial effort of the programmer
to make these two sides talk together
and therefore we are this idea of
creating a language that would allow you
to do mixed side by programming
and apparently this is a good idea
because meanwhile you can find Google
tool kits and echo 2 and other
approaches that are also going in this
direction and there are I think very
good reasons for following this approach
namely well you can avoid this mix of
different programming languages if you
want to develop web applications it
completely avoids this so-called
impedance mismatch mismatch that you
have if there are different data
representations involved and you have to
convert data from one to the other
clearly different languages do have
different representations here and
what's also an interesting point is that
you can get rid of the explicit
programming with networking api's this
is actually something that as far as I
know a GWT does not achieve but maybe
some of you it knows a little bit more
of that then I so we thought that it
would be better not to build a tool kit
but rather build a new language but one
which is influenced by kind of the major
players or by major players in this
server-side and client-side game so the
major player that we selected for the
server-side game was Java the major
player while the client-side game was
JavaScript and then we needed another
major player for the type system side
and we have chosen esco for reasons that
I will elaborate down here in a minute
so well why what is this Java influence
well Java is used for server-side probe
act programming in things like servlets
and javaserver pages and clearly you
need some kind of mechanism to to
interface to interesting libraries and
of course we want to leverage the many
many libraries that exist the many AP is
that exists for Java or actually the
same argumentation could go for a
c-sharp or something like that as well
but we
wanted to make do with Java and use the
power of the Java API well on the client
side there is um JavaScript which is to
some extent standardized at least but
plain JavaScript won't do because the
language has some interesting quirks
with its dynamic type system and so on
that I don't really want to go into
right here so we wanted to get rid of
this dynamic type system instead we
wanted to we want to add classes and
some notion of interfaces to that system
so that you can actually do programming
tasks in the large with this language so
why so the JavaScript heritage kind of
enables you to do client-side web
programming and then with JavaScript
there's also some XML integration which
is called a 4x and you also of course
want to leverage the existing Ajax style
libraries which are also around here so
you want to talk to JavaScript as well
and so we don't want for that reason
here we don't want to give up this
JavaScript compatibility completely but
we're going to restrict the use of
JavaScript with the type system which we
think leads to more robust programs and
two other features like automatic input
checking and so on and this is where the
Haskell type system comes into play the
third way that you might want that you
might want to look at this language is
that you could regard it as a strict has
go with object-oriented features and of
course a different syntax because well I
won't go into syntactic discussions here
so why did we go with has go well in the
last couple of years I've been
developing a system called wash which is
a well and a kind of domain-specific
language for server-side web programming
which is based on hesco and has a few
interesting features that make it fairly
simple to write this kind of web
programs so it has a built in session
model it has stuff like type first
entry fields type call back that you can
bind to two buttons and all that and
lots of this functionality really relies
on features that are fairly unique to
Haskell type system in particular type
classes and constructor classes so the
idea was to well if we have a new if we
build a language then we don't want then
we also want these wash style features
in that language and for that reason we
needed to kind of a transposition of the
type classes into something that is well
that looks more object-oriented and in
fact there is the close correspondence
between type classes and Java interfaces
well and you will you will see that in
in the next couple of slides then of
course one thing that is exploited in
the type class system is that high
school supplies you with named algebraic
types that you can define by yourself
this is basically the reason why we
needed to add classes to JavaScript
usually JavaScript as well it has some
types like it doesn't really have
structure types and it doesn't have
nominal types at all so in order to make
type classes work well you need some you
need to be able to define nominal types
so that's why we are using we are
introducing classes here and in order to
get the remaining functionality of
algebraic types will have Union pipes in
order to put classes together and
actually Union types are a nice starting
point that you can later on extend to
full-blown regular expression types
which are a well-known medicine for
typed XML processing about at present we
are only looking at Union types all
right so um this is basically the
motivation that we that we want to go
down to and then how will this language
become pilot it will be compiled to each
program will be compared to kind of two
parts namely to servlets java servlets
for the
server side and the other script
programs that will run on the client
side and ideally the compiler should
partition the code automatically
admittedly this has turned out to be a
fairly hard problem we're working
actually one of my students is working
on an analysis there but it seems like
you we are getting more leverage there
by actually hand annotating the code
with what you want but anyway it would
just require annotations but then the
compiler inserts the communication
required automatically which means you
don't have to think and program in terms
of networking ap is or what is it called
in Ajax this XML HTTP blah blah blah
thing question
I mean what year what
a lot all right so basically the idea is
that you have certain api's where you
know that they can only run on certain
places yeah for example if you deal with
with windowing stuff then you know that
it must run on the client if you deal
with database stuff you know it must run
on the on the server and then the
analysis determines which other code
remains on the server remains on the
client and depending on which nops you
turn if you want to minimize
communication or if you want to minimize
the workload of the server or the client
you can get various distributions right
i mean in the the the the extreme case
or one extreme case would be that you
say i'm running only the api calls on
the server and then you would have the
the whole application on the client with
kind of RPC style calls to the server
api or you the converse thing would be
to move everything but the but the user
interface staff to the server and then
you would in in the in some cases you
would get there the extreme partitions
that those who can express very easily
yeah yeah yeah so right yes it will be
the analysis that my students is looking
at involves communication cost and
timing and and everything and well it's
still complicated even though we
abstract lots of details away right
okay so i'll give you a short example
program which will demonstrate some of
the high-level features and then
afterwards we'll look a little bit
closer at things at mechanisms that
we've built into the language so on the
high level you'll see things like xml
literals which seemed to become very
common right now then you'll see how we
express input widgets and the
interesting thing here is that input
widgets look really like the standard
HTML input widgets but in addition they
will bind variables for you which you
will see in a minute then another point
here is that you can define actions by
callback functions and the idea is that
the callback functions are attached to
your the elements in your in your GUI
that are like buttons and and things
like that and what we also want is your
automatic and extensible type checking
for each data and free field and here is
a little example program that
demonstrate here these features for
example here between the two hash things
here this is an XML or HTML literal
whatever you want to call it and the
hash thing is actually a special marker
which creates a list of XML document
notes well and here you actually have to
input fields and one submit button so
just the standard web form and the two
names that are printed in red here they
look like ordinary name attributes here
for the input field so that's well these
are correct well forms HTML but in
reality the compiler recognizes these
attributes and uses these two names here
as binding occurrences so this binds a
variable with name MP Y and this binds
another variable with name rpt and these
variables schools
curve as handles to the value that you
enter into these input feels good
gallant set out words that you have
served in education certain namespace or
certain elements I mean or well you're
using but yeah you're using that's just
the standard elements so the idea is
that in writing your form you can you
can take some web designer that doesn't
have any idea of the system you just
tell them go write me the snippet of
HTML for me and well and then then right
yeah and it knows there must be this
name attribute end it uses that to to
bind it so the only thing special is
down here at this input as it's at this
submit button for the submit button
there is a special name space w here
with a special attribute call back and
in that attribute you can specify the
action that's that should happen when
you click the button and in this case
the action is that you call here the
function first exercise which is down
here with the two handles as arguments
question oh yeah that's a good point
that's the next thing that I have to
explain so the machinery that performs
this submission for you see it does two
things now suddenly the it has two
things it sees that's here this function
first exercise is typed so here we're
expecting something of type integer and
we're expecting another thing of type
integer from that it demands that the
two arguments here to the first exercise
must be handles to input fields of
integer and it inserts the correct code
to actually
check that the contents are well-formed
integers before before it allows this
form to submit so there's a similar
mechanism actually in the in the more
system and what that boils down to is
that you only need to write this code
and you get this kind of functionality
that well you right here this wow this
is kind of the snippet of the web page
that you generate from this program so
if you type some silly stuff in here and
try to submit the the page then you
automatically get this error indication
and you can check that out and so
actually this kind of feature is already
present in in wash as well question
actually yes you could have used in as
well
mm-hmm sir I mean there's been other
work on ride wanting to bring static no
static typing and compile compiler time
well i'm including your own work on Wall
back sometime yeah so um let's see so
just to pick one of the systems that
they did they the bigwig system the idea
there is well you are creating this this
HTML form there and then they can
analyze which input fields are contained
in the HTML that you create then they
have some kind of a statement that
allows you to send this list of the
browser and get the answer and what they
provide you then is a guarantee that you
can only access the fields that you have
specified in the in in the input field
right hi here the model is a little bit
different so the forms that you have in
in bigwig only have so to speak one
continuation and in the one continuation
you have to you have to determine what
has been submitting clicked and then you
can access the fields as as you like
whereas here you'll look at this whereas
here this forum has kind of well it only
has one continuation but it might have
many continuations and each of the
continuation already gobbles up the
input that that it wants directly at
this point so later on there's no
further need to check that the values
provided are the parameters provided are
the ones that are expected later on
because
they match up here by lexical binding
and that's the only way to access the
parameters so that's I think the major
difference and that's that's why already
a an ordinary compiler can keep track of
the use of the variables otherwise you
need a special analysis as they have in
the in the table and big wigg system
alright so um what features do we need
in order to to get what we want more or
less so it turns out that we need
generic classes well which is kind of
the transposition of algebraic data
types parameterize algebraic data types
and them with inheritance I only mean
code inheritance so I don't mean
inheritance which also causes subtyping
so it's just inheriting code no um s
from the so generic classes is kind of
you could regard that as heritage
heritage from Java right so the next
point kind of deletes something from
Java namely we will replace java's
interfaces with well you could say
another version of interfaces but this
has caused too much confusion when I
gave this talk earlier so we decided to
just call it what they are let me type
classes so we are using type classes and
set of interfaces and I will show you
what kind of trade-offs that involves
then we'll look at Union types and the
wheel owns also see that you don't need
a cast operation anymore in this
language instead we'll have a something
different namely a type-safe switch
expression or a safe types which
expression and you'll see at the at the
appropriate points where which
functionality is needed all right so how
do type classes look in this kind of
object-oriented setting so as you will
see they look very much like interfaces
but they behave differently and that's
why they have a different name here so
this is a type class called comparable
and it's it tells you that well in order
to be a member of that type class you
need to have a method called compared to
and it has to take a parameter that of
type this returning an end now first
question is what is this this is the
type of the class that is going to
implement the type class so it's 0 and
it's obviously it's related to self
types and things like that which have
been explored by people like Kim Bruce
and others in the object-oriented
community no but all right so the other
point is that the implementation of a of
the method of a type class can be
separate from the class so you don't
need to have all the methods already in
the class but you can provide them later
on as an add-on so here is the
declaration that could have integer
implements comparable with some
implementation here and I've been told
that this implementation is not a very
clever one but nevermind actually I
think it's it can raise overflows or
something like that which it shouldn't
really because it should just compare
anyway so the point is that the
implementation is separate from the
class and then the final point and most
important point is that these type
classes they are not types so there are
not types but instead there they are
stating just restrictions on parametric
types
strike that was a long sound like you
were saying the interface yeah so we
used to we used to call these things
interfaces you said in the answer is
that interfaces I think our times in
these or not something either pieces on
time silent right in Java interfaces are
types and you can use them in wherever
you are not sure I was thinking
interfaces on types in the sense of
having a semantic domain associated yeah
but I mean formally in Java you you can
write an interface wherever you can
write a type right wherever you can
write a class type I mean it doesn't you
know what about all the main really
write it I mean cost is kind of old told
me so I didn't sort of like just
constraints on the valley to me yeah
well so it as it turns out type classes
are not completely identical to Java
interfaces and in a couple of slides you
will see exactly how they are related so
there's Java interfaces haven't have an
additional existential quantification
with them and that's the ed only thing
right so let's see what that gets you if
you if you adopt this for example in
Java 5 you can also write a comparable
interface and you can also write a kind
of binary method like this compared to
the thing but the price is a bit higher
so the comparable interface has to be
made parametric or generic and the
argument type has to mention this this
parameter here now so you instead of
having some self type around or this
time around you have to supply an
explicit type parameter here and in
order to get this type parameter to
behave like this type you have to use
the
reflexive bound trick or recursive
bounce trick such a request that you
replace your pronunciation of one of the
th is is either the problem or the
keyboard now that suggests the keyword
by something else otherwise what you say
just sounds like nonsense you talk about
this parameter or if I might be this
just this okay it's a self instead of
the keyboard if you reduce your own
replacement okay I can do that okay
I believe the next few slides do not use
this cell all right yeah so but I think
this is trick the trick of having a
recursive bound here is is well known
but arguably it's a little bit more
involved too right here t extends
comparable of tea instead of just
writing t extends comparable which is
kind of what you use here also i think
the declaration that something is
comparable is much simpler because
already in the in the declaration that
it that something implements here this
here the generic interface you already
have to use the recursive bone right
then another point is which is kind of
required by the implements declaration
any way that you can supply external
method or methods to classes this is not
a new feature for example multi java as
a as well it allows you to add methods
later on to a class well and I think the
trade-offs here are well known so we
don't need to modify existing classes
you can reuse the code without
recompiling it you have guaranteed
information hiding because the external
methods cannot access private variables
and the implements declaration are can
be seen really as can be seen us here
the composition of an external
declaration of a method and just and
implements declaration
rules are you applying your most
impregnable aspectj and being sort of
global scope I mean everything gets
added and then this it really just one
class in here and everywhere could be
extra efforts and put in there other
things like glass box assembly for local
scoping for extensions so here it's just
double so I mean in the sense that
whenever you know that this extension is
added then the method is also in scope
yeah you need well you need the same
mechanism in order to be able to
separate the implements declaration from
from the class definition which is kind
of handy see you somehow I guess you saw
power associated sort of implicit in
domain name or whatever 50 spice or are
you somehow infer God just wonder how it
corresponds to be so it's a sort of uh
new most interface oil I mean here if
you up
yeah you can view it as that you could
do it like that but what it does is it
extends the meaning of the class string
in the scope where this declaration is
visible yeah they are scoped in a
strange way well I see I see you mean
they on your you're on the go scope but
still you don't import you tight cause
at all yes anyone then exactly then it's
not visible tonight right okay oh good
thanks it may be visible through
reflection or something like that but
this is something that we haven't
considered yet
right another thing is and another
difference two interfaces is that these
type classes can have static methods
typical application is that you want to
read and validate the input of the
content of form entries generically and
the typical way to do that is you'd have
some type class possible which has a
static method that parses a string and
returns a representation of well
whatever object or whatever class
implements here this this interface and
what a normal interface wouldn't work
because well there's an object available
of the of the class type before the
parsing is complete right so you might
call this beats static methods you might
call them parameterize constructors if
you want to you know basically it allows
you to have constructors that depend on
a type variable yeah so this is just for
remembering that self is really the type
of the implementing class all right and
as for the implementation there is not
much new here so you just basically add
a static method to the class that
implements the the type class here's the
use of that namely a method process
entry that gets a field name and then
reads from let's say reads from some
form it reads the string that's entered
there and then parses the string to
return some value of type T where T is
something that implements the possible
interface that extends possible and here
is a typical use of that and this is a
we think this is a fairly nice feature
because
it really avoids an explicit
construction of a generic factory
because this would be the way that you'd
write similar code in Java where you
would do something like this year you
have an abstract class horrible
interface which is parameterize here and
contains the parsing function and then
you need you need a class basically well
in haskell firms would be a dictionary
which is here the class integer
implements possible which extends your
this interface and then you would just
have to extend the parameter list for
process entry by also passing such a
horrible interface here and then instead
of just calling your parse you would
have to call the parse method of this
office factory here now so this already
this also tells you a way of
implementing these glasses namely by
adding extra dictionary parameter which
in this case turn out to be an
application of the factory pattern with
the generic factory right
well now we'll come to the connection to
Java interfaces and the problem that we
will look at is piping for collections
now let's say you want a type class for
collections which contain values of type
a and this is just the very trivial
interface which just can generate an
empty collection and which allows you to
add a couple of elements to that now um
generosity and not having a subtyping
caused by inheritance forces that all
elements of the collections have the
same type and meaning the same class
type and this is a very strong
restriction in many cases in quite often
you only want that all the elements that
you have in your collection that they
just understand the same interface so
maybe they are all they can all be shown
or they can all be compared or something
like that well compare it's not a good
example in this case but if you want to
but transform them into a string or
something like that that would be a good
thing so and of course the answer is the
kind of obvious one you want to hide the
identity of the type and you want to
just expose that the type implements
some interface so instead of asking here
for a fixed type you asked for an
existential type so there you want the
type there exists some a that implements
to string and then this tae BAE and as
it turns out this corresponds this
existential type corresponds exactly to
to the Java interface like to string
which contains a two-string method so
the Java interface is actually a type
plus plus and existential wrapped around
this with this kind of quantification
so s this happens a couple of times well
this is something that you use often in
your programs there are some
abbreviations for that and you can also
use multiple type classes and wrap them
together to your new type yeah but
similar functionality is also available
for Java as far as I know no but in Java
you only have this choice and you can't
have this this type class mechanism
which still reviews the identity of the
type below alright well the next point
in our list was Union types what you
need those for well let's consider this
task you want to define a tree structure
with several different types of nodes
this is if you help this task in a
language in Java like language then you
look at the at the Gang of Four book and
it will tell you use the composite
pattern which means ok we build an
abstract class and then you build your
node types as subclasses of this
abstract class and put the usual
information in that right so in white Oh
me you have you would have to do that
using Union types which are not
extensible and the way you would do that
is you would just define the two classes
for leave and branch with the same body
as in Java and then declare the type of
be tree as the Union type of these two
class types leave and branch and
the line number one we should ignore
them right now so now we've introduced a
new typing construct as it turns out
construction of values of this type is
trivial because the members of a union
type are either our members of one of
the constituent types but now we need to
be able to deconstruct these types how
do you how do we do that well it would
be tempting to include something like a
cast but as as you all know has
introduced all kinds of problems if you
want to for example like proof type
safety so we decided to do the scrutiny
of a union taught by a type switch
statement which has different case
branches for each of the participants in
the Union
it wants to be exhausted so the choice
that this better post but yeah I mean I
would also wonder I mean if you are an
agnostic shop is a seminal construct and
it doesn't have such requirements are
you if you miss the pace and get ready
forward and listen Kasich said yeah but
you know it's like pedal all mostly
women on time yeah SMS chart program
Empire will verify if you get there only
those two subclasses and you can tell
that for sure it will then know that you
won't ever compare to the defalcation
just what I think knowing that I sense a
kind of restriction to help them find
for example abstract syntax type so
using spinnin time and it can be quite
common that I want to get it doesn't
notice or actually actually there's the
effect was a significant shot before
actually I have to confess that we are
talking about a little bit of a moving
target here so the first design that we
had we reconsider its extensible union
type where you could just add stuff
later on with a different declaration
then that would allow you or to declare
oh by the way I'm also a member of the
Union and now we are currently
discussing if we should have two
mechanisms namely abstract classes plus
inheritance for doing this kind of
extensible union and just plain union
types for not extensible unions so
that's that's also the explanation for
the one and two things in this
saw this year as a paper on a sort of
you know I mean space be exploiting cost
extension virtual methods right so I
mean if you take a compass of pattern
and you can inject commercial method off
to the back and you know you can just
implement the case of the types which is
virtual application ah that's there are
some or justify it but as a so our first
stand on that was you would well so if
you have a fixed union here then you
would you would have to have an
exhaustive switch here for the other
case you would also have a default
branch here which would capture all the
other things but it wouldn't you would
have to write this default forensics
explicitly and you would have to raise
an exception if you wanted that to
happen so it's really quite close if you
compare it to to like the hassle tap
system it's really quite close to a case
there
problem like that's irking in and then
we know that again type clauses can help
us to solve this year nope a statement
Oh interesting 143 if you do not put a
default boss else then then you got the
nails the third falls oh so you had to
give all of the cases oh that's
interesting but the compiler did not I
see I'll because the compiler wouldn't
wouldn't see all of the class hierarchy
at the point when it was compiling the
touch which oh that's interesting yeah
so why so did it have cast modular three
also but if you have this then you can
define your own cast right and and that
is the the instance of and in addition
it had to type that I case which is dis
convenient just like here you get in the
case branch B you get to name the
message be which so that's module three
do that as well okay thats in this a
real comedians right and you don't have
to like if you do this in java you have
to write the if statement you learn new
instance of and then do the cast
interviews not just clumsier well well
that's not I think it's not just clumsy
earth it also gives the compiler a
better chance of optimizing things right
because in the branch you know perfectly
well that now I have an object of this
time right yeah so for that reason we
actually prefer this kind of switch
thing yeah the rest I suggest this stuff
can be defined right
but do you also support actual data
matching with some places or it's just a
hard case right now it's just a case
successfully I guess for full java
glasses that's difficult to have a
useful matching Megan's might I mean
scarlet rise to have liked to we haven't
considered tight but but Scala also has
a wanted to celebrate yeah this because
this case class doesn't it which is
really something like an answer right
there is exactly are you giving all the
you know body parts and everything enjoy
it's totally alright and now we come to
the points that you probably were
waiting for now you can do well as you
can make the visitor pattern obsolete
well as we've almost discussed that
already do we need to go into much
detail here I mean it's it's already if
you when you just have these method
extensions that already helps you quite
a lot to to get the visitor pattern so
here the point is you have a type class
with a static method count and then you
basically just declare that leave and
branch both implement count and then
from that definition and and the fact
that this type class well that this
signature for count here is well behaved
you can deduce that also the union type
leave union branch that it also
implements the count interface actually
this is this relation is not trivial
I'm sorry so that so the point is we are
only declaring that leaf and branch
implement the count interface but later
on of course we want to use it on the
union type Petrie yeah yeah but it's not
trivial that from leaf implements count
and branch implements pounds does not
always imply that also the union type
implements the interface for this
interface it's true but it's not always
true it depends on where the self
parameter occurs here and often it
occurs and stuff like that and that
would be indeed very cool of you and my
visitor patterns this way for arbitrary
classes well you well right now you're
not you're not restricted to just use
the components of a union type here
right yes you said you
they start want to call countin on this
side
what what
yeah and also if I have other defines
Union types that contain your branch or
leave and some other stuff which also
implements count also want to be able to
apply to that
the partial classes you know you just
right now we just extend the class to to
implement the map of cattle to whatever
and then you just put this without
separating population right because i'm
not sure what partial classes are also
see sharp asset classes or vb project
ahsha's basically allow you to have you
know scattered slices of your boss's
extended different houses mostly on
about the same time they come together
ah ok oh yeah this shouldn't be
necessary here right just you separately
yeah that's ok so how are we on time so
we finish on time because then I would
jump to the conclusion slide yeah okay
so well as as you may have noticed here
we've used static methods but just the
same game you can also play with the
ordinary methods using extension methods
Wow
yeah I think
yeah let's maybe just talk about this
slide and I won't go into detail through
the code because that might take a
little bit longer another typical test
point which is for example in the in one
of the Scala papers is that you would
like to have a typed version of the
subject observer patterns and the
problem here is that you have a mutual
dependency of between subject and
observer and so in the subject you have
this kind of registration method that
takes an observer argument and in the
observer you have this notify no update
method that takes the subject as an
argument and interestingly the a
standard extension of the type class
mechanism lives up to this problem as
well so in Haskell you have multi
parameter type classes and here you
could extend or transfer that into
multi-headed type classes if you want to
buy well multi parameter type classes
expressed some express some relation
between types stating requirements of
the unease with them and actually you
can transpose that more or less into
this setting and the example code is
well inspired by the Scala paper and it
makes use of a slightly debatable
feature namely that you have default
code in there and because then that's
the problem of where you would actually
where you actually want to put the code
for this this default code and so that's
not completely nice
so basically what you have here is now
instead of having a an implicit type
parameter called this you can name the
type parameter for the two for the
implementing classes by just putting
them explicitly here in this case there
are two classes in roles and we can call
them subject and observer and then in
inside we have we state the requirements
on each class just by naming the class
again and then putting the methods in
these bodies here now so the observer
has to have some update method that
takes the subject and the subject needs
to have a notify method that oh well
here has a register method that takes an
observer and it also has this notify
method that does something to it so as I
said so there are some features in here
that might not live for very long namely
here that you can define variables here
in in a class I don't think this is a
very good feature and this is probably
to be deleted in the future yeah but
nevertheless so the messages is kind of
that multi parameter type classes or
multi-headed type classes can I do allow
you to express also the subject of
server I don't ask Allah uses an
entirely different mechanism doesn't it
so they have these abstract what I
recalls abstracts class parameters
could happen you can have the two
parameters
I would have to look at the have the
paper again well actually to the point
that I want to make is that the same
type class like mechanism can be applied
to this problem just as well it just
seems less how would have that I don't
think they need trades for that I don't
think they need traits for this example
um because otherwise so this place down
here would indicate a parameterized
class right well I'm the only
annotations that we've seen is just
syntactic sugar namely well instead of
writing the comparable interface that
you've seen on one of the first slides
you can also be able to name your
implementing class by yourself and then
include that method signature and this
year it's just more verbose all right I
think we're I think we'll skip over that
yeah so this is the this is the problem
that i mentioned before so if a
implements an interface and B implements
an interface then it doesn't always hold
that also the union type of a and B
implements the interface and actually
this this implication between here and
here may not hold in either direction
depending on what how you use the South
parameter in your interfaces and for
that reason we also allow you to write
explicit implements declarations for a
union type if that can't be derived from
the implementations of the of the
constituents of the union here
um um this is a strange example that I
think
what we've been
you should do that offline and just go
through this conclusion side which slide
which more or less states the status of
the project so what we've done so far is
is this year there is an untyped
implementation of the of the server part
which means there's an implementation of
the language that ignores air well that
ignores clients more or less completely
and just compiled to servlets then there
is a compiler that compiles the typed a
typed version of why tomo to java but
it's not the current version not not the
one that i'm talking about but it's an
older version of of the language and
because the target language was java the
students who work on this had to make
further restrictions so he wanted to
integrate that with java and he wanted
to be able to import Java type
hierarchies and and inheritance and for
that he had to make a number of
compromises compromises well then we
have a we have a type sound as proof of
that and as I was saying one of my
students is just finishing finishing his
thesis on this splitting transformation
and analysis of splitting things into
client and server paths so what we're
currently doing is actually also
revising parts of the language we are
once we've done that then we are
implementing a compiler for the current
version trying to pursue it as students
to do an implementation of their of the
client part as well and one thing I
already mentioned is that we would like
to of the extensive type system to cover
regular expression types which look kind
of the natural generalization of Union
types and then to integrate everything
and get a working system
what that's it thank you for your
patience